I love good marketing and first of all
I've always wanted to be Ken sorry Ken
um this so it's pretty cool we're
vaynermedia my marketing company uh
works with Mattel I think this marketing
is probably under the
TV part of the world so I don't know if
Mattel's doing this or the
or the excuse me the movie part is the
engine is doing the marketing but what
is very clear is that the Barbie movie
marketing is working it's in the
Zeitgeist it feels like it's everywhere
and not just good marketing whether you
do it digitally you integrate it into
award shows you do it with outdoor media
whatever it is when you feel it this is
a campaign that I am absolutely feeling
I think everyone's feeling it's also
playing on Nostalgia there's just a lot
going on the celebrities are struggling
there's a lot going on here but you see
a lot of things with good celebrities
and good Nostalgia that don't work the
Contemporary nature of some of the
social media content the way everyone's
getting involved is just working and
it's a learning lesson for many people
so Kudos little love today